[Music]
thank you
oh they're saying no sound
um
oh no sound on me sound on you oh man oh
oh cause y'all can hear me but y'all
couldn't hear at it
yeah I was talking all kinds of smack I
said what's going on guys I appreciate I
know the uh the podcast was a little
late because I was eating you know I
need I need energy to fight back you
guys when you come at me in the chat I
appreciate the patience I'm not saying
all the extra stuff I said before uh you
should have just been able to hear it I
don't know why uh you know I'm not
blaming myself I'm blaming you you know
you guys put so much I I forgot to hit
the unmute button it's never my fault
it's everyone else's fault not joking
but appreciate ever come through talk uh
to the actual talk about the past
present future game I got my codes it's
me dirt Gregory what's going on dirt
what you've been playing
uh uh I've been playing some old Call of
Duties Call of Duty
yeah you know I'm a bot so I'm getting
prepared
playing a little Modern Warfare
um the uh remastered one
playing a little infinite Warfare and
you know playing a Little Star Wars kind
of going back and forth
oh you're killing it man you're killing
it it's interesting it's interesting
like the whole thing going on with uh
you know the
going on with that right now with Call
of Duty and Call of Duty being like you
could argue back on in a today currently
like it's really happy I'm really happy
what's funny is like what's going on
with Call of Duty can only be
done on the Xbox because they have the
backwards compatibility with the 360
games
yep
so is that all you've been doing like
jumping it
anything else
um nothing new like I said I've been um
still playing a little um Star Wars Jedi
Survivor nothing
playing some of those old ant stream
games you know you know I love old old
games occasionally so that's all I've
been doing man um
kind of wait for Starfield you know oh
I'm definitely waiting for Starfield man
checking the DMS every day every day all
right so you know we got a good show for
you guys man we got some killer instinct
stuff to talk about I'm sure they're
gonna love that I don't know if you're a
fighting fan but we're gonna talk about
it anyway it's cool we got Final Fantasy
14 coming on Xbox I know it's like a
week late but guess what we weren't here
last week and that's what I want to talk
about so we talking about and then we
got a valve news there's been some um
you know some information that that went
on about you know it's kind of
interesting when we're going to go over
I think it's going to be a very
interesting show man I think it is man I
think it is so let's go ahead and uh you
know what's funny I was so
because today's just been a chaotic day
I forgot to put the update the
information in the bottom so right now
it just says this is about it says last
the week before last topic but that's
cool it's cool we're gonna go straight
into a valve News man did you see
the documentary
they were talking obsidian the stuff
they said about a valve I saw that part
yeah yeah I did see that part hello bro
yeah yeah yeah exactly how I saw it
J-Rock posted like a six minute tweet
too or something like that I watched
that so yeah it was it was very
interesting stuff man
it's interesting for people in the chat
that don't know this is there was a
co-op feature in the game early on in
development that they can you know when
we were hearing about them redoing the
process and you know where it was about
was initially delayed because of you
know hiccups and development that's what
it was apparently there are even issues
because in all these type of games they
got that BioWare dialogue you know where
it's like you talk back and forth they
were having a hard time it looks like
the way I interpreted it where having
two people on the screen doing that they
were having a hard time making it feel
you know obsidian-ish and that's that's
the word I'm using I'm trademarking it
don't don't don't do nothing with that
I'll come after you once it's
trademarked I'll strike your [__] down
but anyway so you know they felt like it
was an obsidian so they they they pulled
the brakes went back first on
development and to them making that game
felt feel like their game was important
to them and that's what I enjoyed like
and not to mention we got to give
Microsoft a shout out there I don't know
how you feel about this but a lot of
other Publishers PlayStation might have
done it because they let Corey go back
and redo some of the stuff on God of War
but
there's a lot of developed Publishers
that would have like yo you need more
time nah we good like you you promised
me a co-op experience your ass is giving
me a co-op experience I don't care if
it's busted I don't care if the game
ain't good that's what we're gonna
that's what we sold to the to our
investors and that's why I think these
Acquisitions are good for the industry
you know because situations like this
if they were still independent game
probably wouldn't even be coming I don't
know they probably extended it like a
year that's a lot of money in terms of
how many people are working on it but
Microsoft gave them the ability to
continue working on that game and
pushing it forward you know there's a
lot of other stuff in there but I want
to get your overall opinions on you know
especially the co-op the like the fact
that they took Co-op and that is unlike
Microsoft in the past Microsoft has
pushed Co-op features on the game such
as uh you know a phantom break I don't
think that had it but
um
what's that game the one that peeps
scalebound I remember they were like
really pushing for coffee yeah and
what's interesting is they're like they
sold this game and this is probably the
single hand reason that Microsoft was
more open to buying obsidian because of
the the vision they sold to them but
they're like look
it's not going to be our type of game we
feel like our fans aren't going to like
it doesn't feel obsidianish we really
want to go back to the drawing board in
some ways obviously not restart
development how did you feel about that
because I I personally feel like
very few companies would have gave them
the ability to do that
well I agree with you because
um I don't know if you saw the other
part of the documentary but I actually
watched it on YouTube watch some parts
of it on YouTube and like they was
talking about uh see like people forgot
that obsidian had a huge game that was
canceled by Microsoft in 2012. and that
was such a blow to obsidian they was
kind of pissed off at Microsoft for a
few years man because they had to lay
some people off yeah yeah bro I forgot
the name of the game if if anybody in
the chat can tell me the name of the
game but I forgot the name of the game
but yeah they canceled it obsidian was
pissed off and Microsoft for some years
so they said when Microsoft approached
them they were still hesitant like uh
but when they let them know what they
want they wanted them to be them they
wanted obsidian to be obsidian and like
you said
they like they were going to do co-op
then they realized they couldn't do it
and Microsoft said listen whatever you
guys want to do do it you know I know
the first thing point is going to say
well they should have did that but red
file yeah maybe they should have
but they just let them do the game that
they were doing so I think right fall
was a different circumstance I think
redfall was already too far in
development to change the roots because
you know they were already in full
production you know it seemed like
obsidian
they might have been in the beginning of
full production but they couldn't get
the gain or work the way they wanted it
to and shot at obsidian too because
sometimes it's hard to put your ego
aside this is the way I think the game
should be and that dude said he really
really fought for a co-op experience for
years and he ended up like you know what
maybe not what I want is best for what
we want so he pulled his ego aside and
trust me if you've ever dealt with
egotistic people that is hard to do it
is it's just egos in general I'm not
saying he's an egotistic person it's
just sometimes when that ego in the way
it's hard to get [__] done and he was
just like you know what let's
let's do what's best for obsidian and
not what's best for me let's let's chalk
obsidian's ego not mine
what you mentioned um the old regime of
of Xbox and listen even though Phil
Spencer has been on the Xbox uh since
he's technically I mean not new but this
this Xbox buying Studios and things like
that that's Phil Spencer regime because
you think about this Ninja Theory we
know we heard a story about them they
were not interested in you know being
acquired even though they were still
kind of struggling financially it's
mainly Phil Spencer Phil Spencer yeah
I'm curious because obsidian was so
upset I'm curious if Phil Spencer
wouldn't have been there and showed them
look we're not just telling you this
like we believe this is what you're
gonna get if you think we're lying
I'm showing you and I feel like that's
the reason Bethesda sold because of the
relationship the uh the people from
Final Fantasy he even said Phil was the
single hand reason they that Final
Fantasy 14 has come as a platform look
you can make an argument that Phil
not necessarily has under delivered but
he's had some misses when it comes to
games but he himself
has been probably the single most
positive thing that Xbox could have got
because he is both a gamer and he's an
executive like that kind of mindset but
he has good mixture of them both he
doesn't care about all the money doesn't
care about all the game development he
has a good middle ground now look I I
understand they're spending a lot of
money and we're not seeing a lot of like
results yet but a vow clearly looks
promising they let them go back to the
drawing board you know I would say
Starfield looks promised I don't know
about you Dirk I would say you know
Motorsports you'll probably see more
than that yeah about that here in the
next couple months you know the games
that they are doing now you're starting
to see the fruits of their labor and
I would say and this is just me Phil
Spencer's Vision years ago you're
starting to see now
absolutely 100 because listen
we heard like four examples of Phil
Spencer like you just said with Square
Enix
uh you know we mentioned obsidian
because they were like
um Minecraft he was what he was the
person that facilitated oh yeah yeah
that's true that's true yeah but the
obsidian uh documentary I remember when
I can think of the lead guy there the
studio head there but he was like
you know they let us be us and like you
said that was Phil Spencer I remember
Tim Schaefer from double fine he said yo
man um we necessarily wasn't interested
in being acquired but talking to
Microsoft and realizing they want us to
make games like the games that we've
made before that we've we're comfortable
with that was the reason they said you
know let's go ahead and make this move
because even the obsidian guy he was
like yo man there's no need to worry
about payroll anymore because there was
sometimes they had to worry about
payroll for their employees but all that
stuff is done you know like I said Ninja
Theory you know talk about that either
they just want to Hype over the stuff
that you know because I do think I don't
think there's a mismanagement problem
with Xbox I think there's an overgrowth
problem where they've grown so fast so
quickly and well that's the same thing
they've grown so big so quickly they're
still filling out the Kinks obviously if
you got a large net
and some of the Nets broke with people
like redfall fall they might not hit the
net they hit the the hole in the net and
fall through it so I think you're seeing
situations like that but it's like I
said when you have
20 plus Studios and I think once you
know the once Activision that I don't
even know what it's like what 34. I
think it's 35 35 student views and I'm
gonna yes I'm saying they bind that's
that's done and you have 35 Studios you
it's like I've said over you're gonna
have some Rebel it's just it's just how
it is not everyone is going to be
delivering stuff and what's funny
is PlayStation has the same issue day's
gone
was issues uh returnal had issues you
know it's not just Microsoft that's
having issues with their first party
when you when you manage multiple teams
that's hundreds of people in multiple
teams and multiple times there's
multiple teams in the multiple Studios
that have multiple managers
you're going to have issues with one or
two of them it's just how it is
well I think that was part of the reason
that they wanted to get Publishers I
know redfall didn't work out for them
but they wanted to get a publisher so
that publisher can continue to run
itself
and but at the same time you like
Microsoft don't want to be too hands off
because we saw what happened with
rainfall so they need a perfect balance
of Hands-On
and also giving the team space you know
they need to make that a perfect balance
um you know so listen bro this is great
news
I don't really play Final Fantasy games
like that but it's not about me I do
yeah
there's a final fantasy video there's a
final fantasy video like if you looked
up my channel there is like 30 videos of
Just Final Fantasy and that's not that's
not if I talked about like the Tokyo
game show because uh people I have a
good amount of subscribers that
subscribe to me for that jrpg goodness
coming to Xbox because I would say I
wrote my YouTube channel like like you
you like you do in college you know you
got a masters in something you got to
major in something a minor in something
I have a a major and talk about Xbox
content and a minor and talking about
PlayStation content and I I apologize
that a lot of the stuff I talk about on
Playstation is negative because for the
most part that's what's been going on
here recently but when good stuff
happens I do talk about it it's just for
the most part it's been nothing but bad
stuff
hey it is what it is man
it is what it is
um so uh yeah man so you know Phil
Spencer is doing great things bring your
Final Fantasy 14 Xbox
that's the step in the right direction
my brother yeah and it's just like the
eval thing too it just shows you know
I would say this is a 2024 game easy if
they're already showing gameplay like
they did last time they're they're doing
these documentaries you start doing that
when you ramp it up on your marketing
stuff you know I would say this is like
little sprinkles of marketing stuff it's
only 24. yeah man it's gonna be
interesting man it's gonna be
interesting I think you know if you look
if you really think about it Microsoft
and Xbox could potentially have a game
of the year Contender every year for the
next five or six years
next year is a valid and hellblade
either one of them it'll be crazy about
and help late wasn't games
the year after that I would say fable
fable and the year after that is either
the outer worlds or uh or Elder Scrolls
and you can have both of those in one
year potentially yeah and then probably
get we're not even talking about like
gear six and like all these other random
games that south of midnight South
America just got so much stuff that they
can do yeah they do bro they do
how you do man and I'm I'm happy about
it
meanwhile
uh hey [__] there you go Nixie
go ahead yeah first place hey hey you
know next to you guys you know the first
place thing look man it's not gonna
happen overnight bro
it's not gonna happen overnight this is
not the NFL where you can go from last
to First in one year this is more like
other sports you know it takes years to
rebuild to get better because we got
like they was down bad days see I don't
know nothing about sports but I'm gonna
attempt to sports analogy first the
sports analogy coming out attic right
now
we we got the Tom Brady in the future
but we try to give up in the past right
now
hey I I don't know the hell that even
meant but uh it's just saying we took
like Tom Brady like right out of the
draft and he's just sitting on again
I got you I got you okay because you
know that don't happen in real life when
Tom Brady was after he was like sitting
on the bench
then a guy named Drew bledso got hurt
Tom Brady got pushed up to the top then
he performed
so Xbox has to perform
that's it all right so let's say it's
their time let's move on to Final
Fantasy we talked about a little bit but
I feel like we we need to really Branch
this out
Phil Spencer was you know it's like
playing Wells Waldo first off shout out
to Microsoft for not letting this league
because I didn't hear about this at all
at all
and you know people
what's funny is like I know things I
just can't say things like the the co-op
thing and about I knew about that for
for a year or two at this point but it's
just like
shout out
to them because
this is something I didn't expect
Final Fantasy on the platform
whoo because
you gotta be royal with me you gotta be
real dirt I want the honest dirt right
now
all right did you give up on Final
Fantasy being on the Xbox at 100 did you
give up on score Enix in general being
on 100 I thought Sony was gonna buy him
I listen man I just felt that Sony's
relationship with screenings in all of
these exclusives Final Fantasy 16 for
spoken Final Fantasy VII remake the
Final Fantasy is having rebirth I was
like all these games are going to
PlayStation
they're never coming to Xbox they're not
even timed exclusive so I'll say how the
hell with it I just assumed that Sony
was gonna buy them oh they might buy
them now for sure man yeah they
definitely might be after after seeing
Phil up there I'll all hugged up on on
that man's up on that stage I I could
just see somebody like I don't like this
I don't like this go over there and see
how much money of Microsoft they
offering this they offering US 10
billion well 9 billion 900 100
000.99 we're we're not going this uh
we're not going over that 10 billion
like you're gonna have to match that
somebody's like can we can we put the
the can we put
Spider-Man up for loan how much can we
get from that because like Sony can can
easily
you know raise the funds to do stuff
like this but the problem is is they got
it they gotta answer to investors and
that's a hard spin oh we want to spend
pretty much what the whole company has
in cash right now
that's supposed to run the whole company
not just PlayStation right we want to
buy Square Enix with that it's like okay
what can we and a lot of time when like
big deals like that are made is for
multiple purposes
the reason they spent so much money on
on bungies because Bungie
had multiple purposes than just the game
they had their expertise on multiplayer
they also had the fact that they can go
ahead and work on the movie and TV
aspect because PlayStation's in that and
they also had the fact that
they had another game in the pipeline
there was a lot of things that went with
that deal when it comes to scoring like
okay can we make Final Fantasy movies no
because
it's like we ain't really been very
successful at that okay well what can we
do they can give us exclusive games to
PlayStation
[Laughter]
hey you know Adidas 20-0 just just makes
it some uh
as a member or like a member for two
months Square oh CEO is a Sony lover and
the new CEO wants to wear games on all
platforms do you think that have a lot
to do with it that has a lot to do with
it then nothing change of leadership I
think it's the Phil Spencer thing man I
think you know
so it's like me and King were joking
about it on Twitter on YouTube on the
iron Lords podcast is like two weeks ago
or last week we were like
it's like
I saw a a show called monk once and I
remember Mom yeah there's this dude that
was in jail he's like really big and and
so he wanted out of jail
but the governor he couldn't buy him
he couldn't get a part of because that
government was like nah you stay in it
man so he had that man's took up out of
there and I'm not gonna say how he had
took him out of there and they paid the
dude they already had to do replacing
him in their pocket so so the whole
episode was about stopping him from
taking the governor out because the
moment the new governor came in he was
gonna pardon him so it kind of seems
like like Phil went up there and after
enough time they're like well you ain't
gonna work with us we go he'll work with
the stuff
so you gonna you're gonna do this the
easy ways the hard way looks like they
picked the hard way yeah there you go
there you go man
so yes uh it was a big surprise because
when I saw the news I was like whoa okay
Phil do your thing buddy
anything
shout out to to you know Phil for making
this happen because if anything you know
what this made me realize
um
that we actually might get because there
is a couple games that they're making
that I was like very skeptical if it was
going to happen uh one of them was I was
skeptical if we were gonna get Final
Fantasy Tactics remake
because they're remaking a tactics game
that I love it's called Final Fantasy
Tactics I love that game now you
actually might like that game because
it's like a turn-based game but it's not
turn based it's like a strategy like and
um
I was convinced that game was gone I was
like that game's only on PlayStation and
PC I'ma play it on PC because as a steam
deck but that game ain't coming out for
Xbox but this showed me hope that okay
maybe that will come maybe right and
maybe you know Dragon Quest 12 will show
up on Xbox day and date and and people
it does not have to be in Game Pass I
know Game Pass is definitely something
that's nice but it doesn't have to be in
Game Pass it's a want
but it's not like a dire need we need
that right now
I would prefer just to be on the
platform at this point because you know
I'll buy the game you know I'd like for
it to be in Game Pass save me a little
couple coins or two but I prefer that
game being on the platform over it not
being in Game Pass and you know I've
always had this like conspiracy theory
that sometimes developers and Publishers
leave their game off of play Xbox
intentionally because they want that
game pass back later
so I hope that's not the case I hope
that I've just got that wrong I need to
take the tinfoil hat off uh but there
has been an occasions where I feel like
games will miss the Xbox platform in
like six months show up in Game Pass and
to me
there's no way that these developers and
Publishers aren't noticing this you know
what I'm saying yeah because uh you know
it is what it is you know one thing that
we what I do want to talk about real
quick you know moving on unless you want
to keep talking about Final Fantasy I
know you said
no you move on uh let's talk about the
Starfield marketing you know we we have
we have talked about
this in the past a little bit you know
kids move has made like seven videos and
50 tweets talking about the marketing
starfo let me get this five dollar super
strap from Adidas 20 zero real quick
wrong answer addict Uncle Phil talked to
the old CEO for years and got nothing
now he replaced that dude no I'm joking
yeah someone said uh Kingdom Hearts four
uh that would yeah another one yeah now
I could see a Kingdom Hearts 4 coming
out
all right so
kiss me made like multiple videos and I
actually I should have got kids moved on
here to to he he's been he's been
blacklisted from the Xbox community
yeah people get mad at him people going
mad said he he had his Xbox car took
away
yeah uh so you know
what do you think when it comes to like
the marketing General uh you know is
that something that you because I do see
that they're starting to post that on
like uh the the wind uh the window
stores and stuff I don't know what that
means that they're going to continue
that Trend and put them on like other
forms of advertising maybe a little bit
of traditional advertising but you know
how do you feel right now being less
than a month away from Starfield and we
still haven't seen like like Starfield
like crazy marketing because apparently
it is being marketed there's people you
know posting pictures of Starfield
commercials on Youtube and Instagram so
maybe is it just one of those things
that we're not seeing it because we have
like ad-free of all this stuff I don't
know what do you think
well
I think
his move started this whole topic bro of
Starfield lack of marketing because
nobody was talking about Starfield
marketing or like their uh before kids
move brought it up
then when he brought up a bunch of
PlayStation fans had videos running with
it said what's this game destined to
fail there's no marketing are they
ashamed of the game all this kind of
crazy stuff I saw but when it comes to
the marketing yes they're marketing the
game
adding the old scene you can't please
everybody right do some people want them
to Market this game like Spider-Man on
the side of a bus well it was on the
side of the bus of a bus it was
um attached to some type of juice or
sports drink in the UK but yes it was on
the side of a bus I mean do you want it
to be marketed like PlayStation games
what do you want
so we could have got him to the library
on his because for those of you that
don't I don't know if uh those of you
that Watch Planet Xbox that's a podcast
that means moved to
we argue about this almost damn weekly
at this point it's like look he wants a
lot more traditional marketing and I
feel him on that but traditional
marketing isn't effective it's just not
it wasn't effective back then the only
reason traditional marketing is
traditional now is because less and less
people are doing it there's more
opportunities with influencers YouTube
advertising you know they have more
programs that actual Target what the
actual individual wants that is the
marketing that people do now they don't
just throw a commercial up during you
know
I don't know is it is it is it is it
Friday night Sunday night football I
don't know I don't know I don't know
they don't throw during like the NBA
matches and the NFL matches they don't
do that as much as they used to now they
might throw something out on like the
Super Bowl because there's so many
people at the Super Bowl that it's
there's a lot of people you can go to
but look at someone like Mr Beast
Mr Beast
on the on the video almost averages what
the Super Bowl brings in
yeah so if if they Market with Mr Beast
and they don't mark it with Super Bowl
that's not traditional marketing but one
could argue that Mr Beast has more
Gamers following him than the Super Bowl
would have watching it mm-hmm look
um
like you said
it's not traditional nothing's
traditional anymore people still want
things to happen like it's the 1990s man
it doesn't work that way like you said
Mr Beast gets more views on one video
than most TV shows most channels they
will most channels would pray for
numbers like Mr like one of Mr B's
videos and you know what's funny Mr B
said that he gets so many views that
like he has to either downgrade his
price drastically for advertising on a
video
or make them actually spend what what
his channels videos are worth but
they're they're like they're like Mr
Beast like if I gave you what you're
asking for you've ate my whole year of
budget up
my whole year I can't do work on
anything else so it puts him in a weird
predicament it's like look like I get
sometimes double the traction that the
Super Bowl gets in one video
why should I downgrade my price because
you don't have the money to meet that
demand and I think it's the same thing
with Starfield it's like you know I'm
not going to say they're going to Market
with Mr Beast but you know big streamer
like Valkyrie uh you know Pokeman she's
like one of the biggest woman streamers
on Twitch ninja there's so many huge
influencers that can actually sell way
more comedies of Starfield than the
Super Bowl ever would because guess
who's following these individuals dirt
games guess who's not following the
Super Bowl like that like look they look
there's cross there's cross streaming
obviously you know there's there's
Gamers that that watch football
but I would say
the the the the center pie you know like
the pie chart where it's like this is
the mix this is it's this part here the
part that connects this is smaller than
people think
so you look I'ma let's go back to the
basics you can't please everybody
you can't please everybody
Xbox might think they're doing a good
job of marketing there are some people
that say yeah you guys are doing a good
job and there's gonna be some people say
oh you guys are doing a terrible job
this is terrible why are you not
marketing this game like you should like
I think you should so man you can't
please everybody man for years
Xbox has no games Xbox has no new IP now
they have a new game a new IP and now
that now the narrative is that they're
not marketing it enough you can't please
everybody man
yeah and that's all I'm going to say and
I do think don't get it wrong I I don't
think that they shouldn't traditional
Market at all
I I personally like
the the placement advertising where you
were you advertising a place like you
know School uh you know buses in New
York subways that's the advertising I
think is most effective because that is
not only getting the people oh
starfield's coming out now obviously the
hardcore and All Star Fields coming out
but there's people that know about
Starfield but forget it's coming out and
that's going to remind them they're
going to see you know some cool thing
going on the subway how many people you
think go through the subway in New York
every day no a lot that's what I'm
saying like I feel like the money's
better spent in that area I agree I
agree I do like the physical the visit
like the more physical marketing like I
don't know if if that's what you call it
but like you said on buildings on stairs
at you know uh Times Square or something
like that I do like that a little bit
more so I I do want traditional
marketing
um I don't think it's as important as it
used to be but you know just like you
like every time you go to the movies now
I go to the movies theaters pretty often
they have commercials and sometimes they
show video game trailers I've seen some
Xbox video game trailers in the past
um I've seen PlayStation video game
trailers so yes I think that would make
sense to you know have some traditional
marketing but
you know you can't please everybody man
yeah and plus you see that they're
starting to I will say one thing I can't
go into much detail you know
there is stuff in the background riling
up that makes me think
that's coming you know what I'm saying
like the big Showdown with uh all this
news related to Starfield and plus I
feel like
part of them wants to keep as much
mystery about Starfield as possible
that's why you ain't really seen no
previews or anything like that I think
part of them wants to see that too they
want oh I didn't expect this because you
you know let's say they do a preview and
they show like an hour or two I don't
even know what they're doing a preview
or not well sure they show you an hour
or two of a preview I thought they were
saying IGN was doing one soon I don't
know I thought I heard that somewhere
yeah so cool what they do well but you
know
what I just find interesting is like the
way Starfield is and I don't want people
thinking that I don't want them to
Market their games I want them to Market
their games I just want them to be more
strategic and marking their games now if
they want to go out there and blow 100
200 million dollars in in advertising
then yeah you know what's crazy too how
many times we said that people are doing
too much bloating marketing they're
spending too much money on marketing
that's why games are going so much
higher in cost to make in the moment you
see a company you know kind of rely a
little bit more on Word of Mouth than
normal
it's not enough marketing
you know they had Diablo 4 on the side
of a of a of a a New York building
during all those fires and stuff and
they did yeah I saw the equity with that
I saw that
hey um Abdel said marketing didn't save
for smoking
yes you know at the end of the day
sometimes
you just gotta have a good a good game
yeah yeah that game was definitely
underwhelming all right let's
let's move on to our next topic man yeah
I feel like we we we've talked about
that man we've talked about that let's
let's talk about Killer Instinct
are you a fighting fan I don't know if
you are or no
um yes I am not like I used to be in my
high school years
um make Mortal Kombat guy Ki
Street Fighter taking yeah I love
Fighters not as much as I used to though
but I still like them
all right so
Killens his 10th anniversary
they got um what's the studio name
always be forgetting that name at least
I'm iron iron Galaxy yeah so they got
iron Galaxy back
and
it looks like that there's a good chance
that this game actually is gonna come
back from the dead and you know I don't
I don't know exactly what how they're
gonna go about this but you know tell me
your overall First Impressions when you
heard that they're going to go back give
it a a 4K you know resolution bump up
probably a texture bump up with the 4K
because that's normally what they do
give us some Network updates and do us
some balancing what was your first
impressions my first impression was like
okay
clapping um because we've been asking
for something to go on would kill
anything but and I think iron Galaxy
they're back because I think they had
nothing else to do yeah excuse me if you
if you look at their last two games
they made a game after they finished
season three of killings thing
um in 2018 they made a game named
extension Extinction that game flopped
bad
then they did that free to play game
called Rumble verse that was good it's
just the monetization it got no traction
it wasn't good yeah it got no traction
so I so like we all saw that they closed
down shop on that game earlier this year
they were available
and Field Spencer in the past said they
needed to find the right team to
continue killing instinct
because some people was like yo man what
you gonna do with your least no teams to
the right team
yeah I mean listen think about iron
Galaxy did a pretty good job because
when double healers got acquired by
Amazon if you remember the first team
that did killing sting at launched or
the Xbox one they I I believe they
dropped the first season
double helix and they got acquired by
Amazon
then Xbox got iron Galaxy to finish
season two and season three and then
they left
bring it back so this tells me they're
about to update and all that good stuff
but this also tells me that they're
about to do part two
that range before
crazy man with the two
star field marketing on child support
papers
that I'll get more views than the Super
Bowl to Super Bowl for four years
combined man oh straight up yeah not
everyone watches uh not everyone watches
football but a lot of people have babies
six billion people in the world
um
so yeah yeah I think it's cool man um I
I believe this move
is means there's a future well actually
you know the guy that that that's the
head of um Overkill anything I forgot
his name but like he came on Evo stays
and he said
we're excited to share to something with
killings theme for the next 10 years or
something like that he said
so this isn't just a one-off update and
iron Galaxy is going to leave now
they're going to work on this game bro
I'm moving forward
yeah I don't think this is like a one
thing here's my question do you think
that this needs to overhaul completely
or do you think they just need to just
do a sequel
um I'll be okay with a sequel it doesn't
need to overhaul because the gameplay is
still pretty solid I just played it the
other day for some gameplay
a seat will be good if they don't give
it a sequel they need to rebuild it in
unreal five and then just relaunch it
with the same name because a lot of like
MMOs do that they'll switch engines or
something and it's the same name but
they switched the actual engine that the
game is in and I think that's what they
need to do they need to make it to where
this is the same game if they don't want
to make a full-blown sequel you know
make it huge update like three or four
characters uh change it to another uh to
the unreal better net code and then like
go all out because I feel like this is
to get engagement but I have every
confident that they are they have a
small team because apparently that
studio is Big it's not a small Studio
it's not like 200. yeah really it's got
like 250 people that's what I heard I
don't know
damn let me look it up so it's going to
be interesting if they go through with
that because let's say they have 20 or
30 people working on you know the 4K
textures and the upgrade to net code and
you know the balancing updates and stuff
and they have the rest of the studio
working on a big big update or maybe a
sequel
you know
one thing yeah you're right you're right
two two one three the employees one
thing I want to ask you you know we'll
get into
uh because I I do want to talk about the
skill incident thing I got another topic
after this
but when it comes to this Killer
Instinct
do you think
let's talk about
iron galaxy do you think they should
just pre-actively just buy them
so this doesn't happen again
that's a great question Alex because
here's the thing I I I've been very
vocal with them just
chillaxing on buying Studios unless it's
something that makes sense like I said
that's something that they need to
strengthen their weaknesses
I think they actually need iron Galaxy
they don't need to have iron Galaxy walk
out the back door again and then they
don't get Killer Instinct for like seven
eight nine years again
I wholeheartedly agree with you because
Killer Instinct is the game that
people's been they've been acting asking
for free for years
when it pretty much was done in 2018
people have been asking for it for years
I remember Maximilian
um oh that was named dude like
Maximilian dude or whatever name is he
yeah he loves the game and he was trying
to get something started years ago like
bring back hey I bring back chaos
trending so yeah it was and so what you
said is absolutely
um yeah man because
this is a Xbox on IP obviously right
they have their own fighter
and I believe having a dedicated team to
this game is is a
it's something they need because like
you said if they don't own them there's
always the possibility this team can
leave just like double helix did they
got acquired by Amazon
um just like you know I don't know I
brought this up on my show the other day
remember Crackdown three of course
that great Cloud destruction that was
shown off in 2015
that company Cloud Jing got acquired by
Epic
and then Microsoft had to figure out how
to do it themselves and we saw how
Crackdown 3 turned out even though I
liked the campaign so yeah you don't
want these teams to leave because you
don't own them so I do agree with that
they knew me if if they're going to move
forward with the killing instinct uh IP
if they want the IP to remain relevant
they got to buy iron Galaxy because
they've shown that they can do quality
killingston content actually I was
looking because when I was doing a video
on uh kill Instinct I was doing a little
research and I was watching one of like
a fan made documentary that they were
going on I noticed that
the first the the first people that made
Carolina Seaton second had completely
two different approaches to Killer
Instinct
like he made he made the example that
Django or jungle or I don't know his
name the the dude that's on the cover
everywhere
had an ability where he would heal
himself and keep in mind on watch it I
don't play head-to-head so I don't know
anything about this
in this community
thought it was broken and they're like
nerfed this it's too much we can't fight
it they did that for the longest time
Dirk
so
and we've seen
companies like Bungie
uh you know I would say 343 to some
degree
they listen to the community sometimes
too much
he was like we think his healing factor
is essential to the character at that
time I don't know if he still has it but
what we want to do
is we want to find out why it's busted
it's got to be more than just healing
and they and they realized that there
was a reachability that got them because
he was good close range mid-range the
way he was describing it and he had an
ability that got him out of his his bad
zones and because they said one of the
things that they found is he had no bad
matchups why doesn't he have any bad
matchups so they wouldn't have okay it's
because he's got this ability that gets
him in close really fast so they Nerf
that ability
and then they said people still complain
but after a month no one said anything
about a sailing ability anymore because
they took away the biggest thing that
kept him on you
that's like like that was when that
documented me wasn't it yeah yeah
because I remember hearing that story
yeah a couple super chats Munch with the
10.
I want to know why people pray Square
Enix and put them on the same pedestal
as Capcom did we forget about Marvel
Avengers cocoso Kokomo GP Babylon fall
was spoken byline Wonderland all
mediocre month said he is not a fan of
square enes and why are they getting
praised at it let me get this uh super
let him say that never and then we'll
never put them up they were Capcom uh G4
with the two dollars who has the steam
deck and is it worth it I have a steam
deck I'll talk about it one second I
think the reason final score Enix first
off they're like an OG OG's always get a
little bit more slack than like newers
come Studios uh they have beloved
franchises Dragon Quest uh you know
Final Fantasy so when you have these
beloved franchise sometimes you get
passes that you shouldn't normally get I
will say that you just named a lot of
misses and they you can argue they have
way more misses than hits these days
obviously octopi traveler occupy
traveler two people liked I really like
triangle strategy I thought that was a
fun game like they do have really cool
knacks and cool like especially like
double A indie games
and it looked like they're going to
actually stop doing those did you see
that article or they said they're going
to focus more on AAA products and yeah
that was weird yeah so you know you
Fair argument and I think it's Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy Dragon Quest keep
that company alive especially Final
Fantasy you know remake Final Fantasy 7
remake you gotta consider this is like
one of the most beloved franchises in
existence and that is the most beloved
game in that franchise and Playstation
is able to keep that on their platform
only
that that lets you go a long way with it
now if you don't like Final Fantasy
games or turn-based games or jrpgs in
general then maybe this isn't for you
and you don't understand the love but
people like me I grew up with Final
Fantasy played eight seven six five four
three two I played ten I played 12. I
beat all of these games you know I
hadn't play a whole lot of 14 but I put
still put like 25 30 hours in the game
so you know I love the Final Fantasy
universe
let's do finish fitting
yes
okay oh you like that one too that was
okay
like this this is Final Fantasy till 10.
this is 12. it's just it's not going up
it's not going down
this is 13.
and then it's going down and like 15 it
just barely goes up but it's still going
down and then 16 is like
what about 10-2
was okay but it still was turn based I
like the direction they took it in terms
of like revisiting a world that you love
but you know I I felt like it was mainly
designed for women because it really
went towards like fashion and stuff and
that's their game you know it I I still
played it I beat it and I like the way
they attributed the game but I did feel
like it was it was made for me but it
wasn't directed towards me do you know
what I'm saying yeah true
you know 10 was the only one that
actually put some time into 10 is great
Titus
it was like Blitzball
I got obsessed with that thing man
because one of the characters doesn't
walk Us in order to get his Ultimate
Weapon because you in Final Fantasy 10
you you get an Ultimate Weapon but it's
useless
you have to get you have to get two
items with the Ultimate Weapon to make
it strong and one of them uh you got the
world championship which was in
Blitzball you had to win a tournament to
get that ability to get that one cool
cool so yeah we're playing a bunch of
Blitzball I would I would just like make
because you could customize weapons I
would just make a weapon that wasn't
necessarily better as it but it was just
as good it just took a lot more it took
a lot
five dollar Super Chat from Ray rampert
Jay Rembert
certain Infinities should be first and
foremost before any other Studio
I feel you on that but thank you
Dynamics
I feel you on that but I I personally
feel like there's multiple Studios that
make games just as good as those there's
very few fighting Studios out there and
if they have the opportunity to pick up
any of these Studios that have fighting
expertise they need to do it
no I agreement
all right so okay
let's let's get on to the the second
part of this Killer Instinct
conversation
um
they just picked up a they're about to
pick up ABK they picked up Bethesda they
picked up all those studios in 2018.
do you think that they should focus on
bring on making Killer Instinct like its
own Super Smash Brothers but Head to
Head put Master Chief in there put uh
you know atriox in there like just fill
it with other franchise characters to
really give it that extra umph
uh you mean
nki yeah and imagine Doom Slayer I'm
sure man sure because they did it before
yeah they did it before with General ROM
with rash oh was it rash yeah uh yep oh
that'll be fire like like uh like before
they had the Arbiter they had General
Ram they had um
rash from Battle so yeah I wouldn't put
big characters like Master Chief
I wouldn't I Think Jesus
is there a particular reason why you
wouldn't want it like I understand like
it's the size of the character you think
was there a particular reason why you
don't want him in the game
um I don't think Master Chief needs to
be in that I think they can choose
another character
Anders is that his name no the one that
died in one of them
it was the black two uh Johnson Johnson
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh you like the like
the general yeah
uh if if he had he was in a mech suit
because he's in Halo Wars too he's in a
mech suit yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
like a character like that now this is
my opinion atriox I think would be a
better fit than cheap wood
Foreigner's in it where Arbiter turns
evil in the in the Killer Instinct game
and master chief shows up to help you
fight him
like they introduced him again and the
story in the same thing because they
already have already in there yeah I
mean already in there but I don't know
that's just me that I don't think like
Chi for or Marcus Phoenix should be in
the Ki game but I can see other
characters being in there like
um maybe you put Kate in there
life no life from Gears in there or you
know like I said Sergeant Johnson or
somebody you know so there's definitely
they have they should add it right so
many new ideas
yeah I would like that yeah I like that
I'm curious on how they would handle her
costume because Cortana is essentially
it wouldn't be the one from four it
would be probably one of the older the
older uh because the one from four she
was breeding was naked
actually an infinite they put more
clothes back on her
um so yeah but listen the Xbox has a lot
they're going to have a lot of Ip Man
like
they have a lot now Cinema
would fit a a dog ones that they put
crash in there
tell me that wouldn't be lit to have
crash that would be funny bro but
imagine
if he throws the the Hat whatever the
floating
all you see is you hear him say that and
crash throws it at you just I mean life
is fun you know you know that'd be cool
for fun but I would say
even though Ceno is a big character in
my eyes she would be perfect though
Cinema that'll be that'll be perfect
really I said crabs versus rash look
some people say you got like I get it
like a lot of the evil peoples in this
game and I feel you were like a monster
but I don't they gotta break that like
this has got to be to me to be
successful like mad successful it's got
to go the same thing with fortnite where
it's like they can introduce other
characters from other franchises and if
my and especially Microsoft just keeps
it in people they own
yo it every like three months three or
four months I added a new character yeah
it's definitely possible with with IPS
they're going on yeah and I get it I
understand what you're saying often I do
but
if they would look past that imagine
like a crash a Crash Bandicoot stage in
a crash uh character imagine like the
character designs like I just feel like
if if you really looked and just and
they were more open-minded if that's the
way they do it that's the way they do it
but if they were more open-minded I feel
like they'd make more money in the long
run
conqueror
would fit more than banjo would in this
game at it uh
uh I want them to bring I want banjo in
it I ain't gonna lie yeah
I need something to make this character
Alex don't start it man and Patrick
Kazooie gets in this game I think we can
actually finally get a magic suitcase I
gotta get banjo kazoo and everything
lunch boxes
oh man
but this is you know I love this this
discussion because
all the IP Xbox is about to have bro I
even think about letter from Diablo 4.
like you could pretty much put any of
the main characters from Diablo in the
game yeah man well imagine if they put a
uh
a Dragonborn the the Dragonborn dude the
dude with the the uh the helmet on that
they always use to represent the
Dragonborn in Skyrim
final shooter from Alvin don't get me
wrong I'm a fan uh I'm all for a ten of
characters added just want to keep the
edge that killing she has and I feel
that but I agree with him well what I'm
saying Alvin is not necessarily like I
know that's gonna break the immersion a
little bit I just want what's best for
Killer Instinct I don't even care about
the damn game it could go away tomorrow
and it's not going to bother me I just
don't want like the K megas and the
maximilians to have to deal with them
not having this damn game again so let's
let's do it right the first time and
they have plenty of characters they
could probably make
the standard characters that you feel
Alvin deserve to be in this game like
the villains the monster type of
creatures they could do that for the for
a foreseeable future there's plenty of
those people that's in this game there's
plenty of them but I do feel like
even though that they have plenty of
those characters there might be better
choices to put into the game because
it's going to be better for the
franchise
and imagine if kill instant gets so big
where like a company like netherrealm
wants to make a Mortal Kombat versus
Killer Instinct that's the goal the goal
is to make it make them Ascend to the
next level and I I would not be pretty
fire Killer Instincts always been up
there with like Mortal Kombat that's the
reason it's coming back to all this time
yeah
well I want to put a chaos up there with
Mortal Kombat no I just say I I would
say not necessarily all on the same
level but it's around that where it's
like it's it has a beloved franchise
in the top five
probably I'm behind you know MK
Street Fighter Tekken
after killings
yeah I'll put the top five they're all
fighting franchise they're all like
to me
I'm just saying this because I'm not the
biggest like head-to-head fighter but I
understand the the demand and want for
that and if they want to go beyond the
characters like I saw people in the chat
people from Resident Evil would be a
good fit you know a tyrant like but I
think they're probably going to stick
more to their IPs they own because it's
going to be cheaper on them to do it
yeah of course of course let's retract
from Pixel bit G if you pick somebody uh
cameos break out if you don't understand
Ki it's entire roster is full speed of
mainstream characters Tusk and Connor
florgo is Terminator I didn't know for a
girl well I see what he's saying it's
like they're like kind of you know spoof
characters like Tusk is Conan the
Barbarian or girl Terminator so I
understand what he's saying yeah I mean
pretty much based all these characters
off other people on other on other
characters which was there is you know
because I would say TJ combo was like
Apollo Creed or something you know
there's definitely two yeah there's
people that's the new studio I Galaxy
made
and I think they say hi right I had like
eight months to show uh to make that
game no it was like four weeks or
something it was it was a character like
they said when they showed it to like
the higher ups it didn't even have some
of the animations like yeah they're like
this is what we think this is what he's
going to look like
but he needs work that's how they yeah
that's right because TJ camo was not in
the first batch yeah he wasn't yeah
hey that's what was in that thing okay
so let's go to this uh last topic man
because I realized you know this is
something that we really should talk
about
Xbox series X mid generation refresh we
talked about this a couple weeks ago
it does look like that there is some
chatter some chattery chatter chatter
going on about this
looks like this actually might happen
uh first off how do you feel about
midgetary first you know how I feel uh I
want your in detailed thought process on
that and then after you tell me your
thoughts on mid-gener refresh do you
think Xbox actually needs one
well
um I'm going to say this you know I said
this before but I'm going to say this
again last generation they made sense to
me
medium refresh has made sense you know
the PS5 4 Pro and the Xbox One X made
sense this generation they don't make
sense to me because the majority of the
generations we've been having cross
generation games even some games like
Starfield Jedi Survivor That was
supposed to be next gen only now we're
hearing that they're going to Port it to
the PS4 and Xbox one so it's kind of
like we haven't gotten anything out of
these consoles I mean you know the games
look good don't get me wrong but none of
these games have blown me away
um
I would say you know maybe Faber will be
that game maybe hellblade will be that
game
but as of right now I don't I don't
I don't really think we need them on
either side now me being the Xbox dude
if XBox drops one of course I'm gonna
buy it
um I don't think I'm going to get a PS5
Pro this generation but like I got a PS4
Pro last generation I don't think I'm
going to get a PS5 Pro but I just don't
think they're needed this generation
because I don't know
you will be getting it strictly for
I guess if it's possible every game will
be 60. that's cool
um but is that worth 500 extra dollars
you might as well get to a PC at this
point in my opinion
I agree with you okay now I will say
this caveats to this um if
I do think they need a mid generation of
PlayStation as one and because I do
think the past couple the last couple
years of the generation be very rough if
obviously even if the PlayStation 5
version runs like dog [__] if that
PlayStation 5 Pro runs good that's all
that media is going to talk about
to talk about that I I also feel like
this is one of those like weird
scenarios where they need to really you
know check with stuff they need to make
sure that there it runs correctly and
the reason why I agree with you that you
know we they
we haven't really got too many games
that really take advantage of the power
at the same time by the time we see some
of these games like the Fable you know
maybe outer Worlds 2 or whatever this
comes out because you know I think Colt
said 2025 he would expect one
um I don't know but if it does come out
in 2025 if they don't do it sooner
rather than later it's going to be too
late if they don't start working on them
the moment they find out PlayStation is
doing one
that automatically proactively just go
start doing it because at the end of the
day I'd rather them have it and not need
it than to need it and not have it
because we don't we both know like
I don't think there's such thing as a as
a a media bias I think there's a media
bias towards whatever gets the most
clicks
this week
the medium I see we talk a [__] about
PlayStation we about to get paid next
week talking [__] about Xbox we've got
to get I agree with that I I do agree
with what you just said I think I've
always said that I think the reason that
it was so bad on media last generation
is because there wasn't many times where
it wasn't getting them paid talking snap
about play Xbox Xbox it was popular to
hate you know oh my God it was so
popular they had on Xbox
that's what everybody did it but you
know yeah I agree man um
I would say this I think if it goes this
way remember last generation there was
rumors about the PS4 Pro before there
were rumors about Xbox project Scorpio
and Microsoft somehow officially
revealed project Scorpio before
PlayStation reveal PS4 Pro
and when they were saying this the most
powerful console ever by the time the
PS4 Pro was announced people was like oh
that ain't that ain't nothing probably
just Scorpio is more powerful so who
cares if XBox can somehow do that again
like say PlayStation
Pro is coming out next year but they
don't announce it until next fall
if XBox goes like shows up in their
showcase next year and yeah we have a
next-gen like a mid-gen refresh coming
in 2025.
and they will steal the Thunder from
PlayStation again but you're right like
you said something
when they drop those men's Refreshers
last generation
nobody even talked about the Xbox one
doing like console comparisons anymore
it was always focused on the Xbox One X
and how it beat the players the PS4 Pro
so yeah you're right about that you said
they're not going to worry about how the
like the original PlayStation 5 isn't
running certain things a certain way is
it they're going to talk about the PS5 I
just I don't want when these games is
coming later generation like Elder
Scrolls uh outer worlds too because I
would assume these games are going to be
the last like year or two of the
generation
I don't want those games
getting
talked down on just because
they don't run the best on their natural
console like but if there's an Xbox
series
X2 and that runs it the best I think
that's better for them because I just I
know how it's going to go a digital
Foundry is going to compare the series X
to the PS5 Pro and it shouldn't really
be comparable we know it's going to get
compared and the first thing you're
going to see is why now you're not going
to talk about the game
you know Hellboy II or outer Worlds 2
could get a 90 plus they're going to
talk about the performance oh this
game's bad and that's another thing you
know when you when these reviewers are
reviewing the game most of them are
going to have the current up uh the
current Hardware if it's if it's a pro
or a series two they're gonna have that
right I don't want to give them any
reason to to score outer worlds lower I
want more 90 meta critic games on Xbox
and I ain't trying to give anyone
any excuse not to do it if it's
performance
they need that extra extra Hardware to
make sure that that performance ain't
gonna hurt them
yep I agree with you man
that's my only thing man I just
I don't want to see what happened at the
beginning last generation because it got
better towards the end of last
generation but most of the generation
last year was the slaughter Fest like
attic you know I talk about this all the
time on my podcast
the Xbox One the first four years before
the Xbox one next came out it was bad
they would absolutely destroyed because
they it was weaker bro Xbox had better
games the first three years way better
games than PlayStation
way better exclusives and nobody talked
about it no it was about the power it
was about the power as people keep
talking about the announcement for the
Xbox series at the Xbox One
and it was TV TV TV and the actual E3
that's revolved around the game oh [__]
it was a great E3 but games and it was
it was a hell of a e3 it didn't matter
their choice by that time absolutely
addict I said that if people watched
that Xbox 2013 E3 it was amazing
they had nothing but games bangers
throughout the whole show
what hurt them was when Phil Spencer
announced the price
and that interview afterwards with Don
mattress said if you want the internet
360 and Playstation went on their stage
said yo this is like the PS4 oh my God
they they killed Xbox that day and I was
as Xbox fan I was like oh my God what's
funny is what's sad about it is the 360
was such a smashing hit now yes I said I
said smashing it okay it was it was such
a good hit
that if if XBox didn't get so full of
themselves with TV TV TV and came out
with a traditional console last
generation
I don't think that momentum would have
been hurt at all I think it 100 agree it
would be maybe not as popular as the
PlayStation because a lot of people
don't like American companies but I
think it would be close to the
popularity of the PlayStation
let me tell you the reason that Xbox was
selling so well and out selling
PlayStation so bad during the 360 was a
variety of reasons but it's because they
were out selling the PlayStation like
five to one in America absolutely
they outsold the PlayStation by like 20
million consoles I did at the end of
that generation let me say this
what you said was true man
um XBox them sales if you watch that
documentary they said at the end of the
360 generation Xbox set themselves up
they set themselves up to be the market
leader the the following generation
because Xbox 360 was amazing like you
said a smashing hit they were such a
good position they had the card deal
going into last generation they had
multiple multiple time exclusives on
lock because of it I didn't fall think
about that Titanfall wasn't exclusive EA
doesn't do exclusives
but they did
they did bro and um I don't know if you
ever saw this article did you see that
they offered PlayStation Titanfall first
I didn't know that they said if I
remember correctly they said they'd make
it a PlayStation Vita game
and that's the reason they didn't go to
them
wow so PlayStation one the video that's
crazy but I I do remember I do remember
Vince impeller saying um he thought
at first he thought Xbox was going to
destroy
this like last generation Xbox one but
that was before all of the policies and
DRM all that stuff came out because the
Xbox 360 was that dominant in America
and you know the PlayStation eventually
caught up for its console sales but Xbox
nominated that generation even with the
red rings well you know a lot of people
ask Microsoft to buy respawn back in the
day I'm glad they didn't because respawn
has turned into its own beast and I
don't know if they would have done that
under Microsoft rain I feel like
the direction that respawn went to can
only happen under a third-party
developer a publisher because they were
giving a little bit more options to what
they were doing you know if if who knows
if you know uh if Apex Legends would
have came out if it was just Xbox
Microsoft might have pushed them and
they probably would want to have made
you know Titanfall 3 or Titanfall 2.
they could be better they could have
made Titanfall 2 could have been one of
the best games ever made if they were
made under Xbox or Direction I don't
know but for some reason I'm just glad
that they didn't buy that company
because I felt like we wouldn't get Jedi
Survivor Jedi Fallen order you know
there's certain Studios that do flourish
better on their own with with like a a
big third-party publisher and there's
some studios like obsidian that I feel
like they've done as much as they can by
themselves and they needed to be picked
up to four they needed some help yeah
also Ninja Theory I feel that same way
they did as much as they can by
themselves
um yeah I mean I see what you're saying
I would tell you one thing respawn sing
with handily say VA
yeah bro
we're doing this defense way yeah and
they say you know what let's give this
guy a promotion
yeah he's doing a lot like he's pretty
much like one of the the most he he's
like one of the the highest up people in
EA these days absolutely man isn't he
over the battlefield Battlefield now
yeah yeah imagine what it's like to have
someone come over from like your
competition back in the day because
remember when Titanfall came out right
before Battlefield and he's like I was
your your ebony
yeah but now I'm telling you what to do
this is how this is how we respawn do
things like yeah straight up man but
look he if he can fix battle if anybody
can fix Battlefield as him bro cause he
was behind the amount of warfare games
back in a 360 generation man I mean the
dude hey Titanfall was a beast man one
was amazing
even without a campaign and part two the
campaign was just incredible so yeah man
um
it's nice talking about we need to do a
podcast one day just talking about old
stuff old event oh man I do it all the
time I do it all the time bro you know a
guy my age I love talking about the old
the old days like especially last
generation like like people's in the
chat say dirt they beat your legs last
generation a lot of people don't realize
how bad it was especially being an Xbox
content creator you know if I look on my
channel let me see
my channel real quick I I have it up uh
my oldest video I made was
two thousand I love that two thousand I
love that YouTube really use no content
back in 2014. I know our Lords had just
started wow no I almost didn't start
till like 2016 17. okay so you was the
dang you was doing wow that's pretty
yeah I have videos on the original
Titanfall Fable Legends
Halo 5. I'm gonna go back and look at
some of that stuff bro because I love
that YouTube video where Tomb Raider is
a timed exclusive
I gotta go back and look at some of this
man because I like that YouTube added
that like they had it before then they
left where you can go trace it straight
to a channel oldest video now they added
that back so I've been looking at old
videos of content creators I gotta look
at that let me put let me put this on
here real quick you guys gotta see this
I get I got made fun of for this like a
lot like a lot let me flip this over
here
all right I'm gonna bring it up here
actually I gotta show the right one okay
right here all right so here's my my
channel let me close out of these all
right so here's my oldest videos I'm
going to show you guys let me see the
look of my phone yeah this one right
here is my cousin he made the very first
video that came on my channel my cousin
wow uh so Destiny Beta that beta for
Destiny damn
uh Xbox games for go for August that was
June uh July 28 2014.
I got Titanfall only on Titanfall it was
like a montage could Halo save Xbox that
that was Halo 5. I I've made like three
of these videos but that's besides the
point
and then uh sorry Sony Fanboys it
happened that was the Tomb Raider he was
constantly worn back then
um this is Diablo dear Sony I don't even
know what some of the look at these
videos I knew you was a bot addict look
at look at these views like these Diablo
views hey ten thousand sixty thousand
ah
Destiny I have a video on here uh where
where IGN took too long to interview
Destiny to review Destiny I said they're
reviewing Destiny Rock by Rock Microsoft
bought Minecraft I mean I've been doing
this for a minute people just didn't
know it stop hating on Destiny and then
I said yeah uh Microsoft owns Minecraft
I said uh Notch is leaving Minecraft
special thanks why no Destiny that's
when I said they were uh yeah here IGN
reviews Destiny Rock by Rock and this is
back when I was a destiny hater when I
was a destiny eight shadow of War Shadow
of Mordor review I did that Final
Fantasy 15 thoughts for those people
that say I I I've just recently on the
Final Fantasy thing I've been doing this
Final Fantasy thing since the beginning
why we fell in uh
why are failing for for the gaming media
tricks
this is where I reviewed Shadow of
Mordor
exclusive Phil Spencer interview
that wasn't online that was someone that
was Project Spark remember that oh that
game sucked Assassin's Creed Unity
Sunset Overdrive update evolve I have
caught it on evolve dude
if that trash can kit smooth versus
black buster credit
oh man where's Bibles Equity is he still
around I don't know
uh uh the apostrate cow I forgot about
that dude that was one of the anchormans
what's his name apostrate Cow
yep I remember him yeah I remember him
yeah I respect video to USA I I've been
doing this for a minute
uh the order 1886 deserved this much
hate
that was a beautiful game but it wasn't
much of a game bro I made this video
because people were complaining in my
clan on you know the host uh how much
money the host deserves and GTA I said
does the host on GTA 5 deserve a bigger
cut in heists
I can't my Shadows came a long way look
at these garbage thumbnails
Sony found new new Destiny bundle
I didn't even make thumbnails on my
videos for the longest oh Arsenal
remember Arsenal yeah I use the light
Arsenal then he turned to a PC Fanboy
and start talking trash by Xbox and all
that
unsubscribe I did a lot of you uh
Duke Nukem wants to make another uh
gearbox wants to make another Duke Nukem
didn't they make that and then like yeah
it didn't it didn't go too well I did
this how-to and it did 10 000 views
look at you man yeah look at this too
much it's fun going back through your
old content
you say what 241 000 on this Fallout 4
chat video goodness did you monetize
that video
oh you oh you might not have had a
thousand Subs back then I think I had it
at that time yeah damn that was a Fable
four see I don't be just changing I I'm
about this life Fable four you know I I
think this is when I started like taking
like thumbnails a little bit more
seriously this is what I I got an Xbox
series X a little early before everyone
else because I went to uh a Fan Fest
that year
Skyrim this is when Skyrim came out for
last gen yeah see you can see I'm
starting to take thumbnails a little bit
more seriously
like Final Fantasy 15 uh this video did
pretty good for considering my channel
back in the day
it was the jet for uh remake Jet Force
Gemini mm-hmm
you have Final Fantasy I've been doing
this for a minute man I've been doing
this for bro your views are crazy you'll
have if you were to say 3 000 in your
next video you'll have 11. that's
because there's a lot of how to's at
that point yeah like oh yeah look right
here on the next page is EA access work
on PlayStation 4 8 000 views
and what's funny is this didn't even
this this didn't even get the views it
did until it came out for PlayStation 4.
originally EA access was only on
Playstation uh was only on Xbox Xbox
right yeah so it was years before that
video Skyrocket oh look this is where
you start slowly seeing my uh thumbnail
style originate
because uh now my thumbnail is like this
but it's different
it's like more colorful and stuff this
is when I first started playing around
with that thumbnail style okay I see
except for I flipped it
like the pictures on the right and on
the left
the very first thumbnail I made doing
this yeah see this is when I actually
had it built
I actually Escapist too I made multiple
videos for that 35
000 40 000.
yeah it's it's crazy man I'm trying to
find out the first video that I yes
another Fable video I told you I got a
lot of favor I got how to fix cfd's
video
another Fable video so you're you're
about to start seeing like my my newest
thing yeah see this is when I really
started taking thumbnails seriously like
I actually started getting familiar how
to use like editing software and stuff I
have a who makes better Halo bungee or
that got almost 8 000 views that who
yeah see I reviewed a bunch of games
back then
oh we're about to get to it yep it's
it's it's it's this next page
this is the first video I did with the
type of thumbnail I have now
this PlayStation reveal event back in
2020 I at the same the thumbnails I have
now they're they're that same style just
a little bit different
and these are the thumbnails I have now
so yeah that's what that's why I'll be
laughing when people like think I'm new
like nah like some of the first people I
met in the doing content don't even do
content anymore like the only thing a
lot of guys not around the only person I
can really think of is like kids smooth
uh he still does content BG obviously
like there there's a lot of people that
still do content but they you can ask
like especially dirt you guys dirt like
there's been so many people going in and
out of the content creation I remember
back like nothing but shots that's like
a that's like a weapon wheel before a
weapon wheel
nothing but shots I don't remember that
one yeah that was a podcast it's got
nothing but shots it was literally
weapon wheel probably more disrespectful
than weapon well that was going wild on
that [__]
I remember man so many different
channels I see rhythms I remember I
remember there was a PlayStation guy
that he didn't last long his name was
Turtle Jack Turtle sale Jack turtle
shell oh he was the biggest Xbox hater
this dude hated Xbox but he stopped
doing content there's so many guys that
stopped doing content like Arsenal was
one of my favorites you know kids move
was one of my favorites you know next
gen
yeah it was so many guys I used a lot of
their content and things like some of
them just stopped or some of them
they're still around but they don't do
content anymore like red dragon you know
stuff like that
yeah yeah I used to love take Hawk ass
Joey I was on that channel for years
yeah that's where I remember IOP
originally was I remember
I remember right we're gonna go ahead
and end this show guys I I apologize
because I saw people say enough with the
history I just yeah I definitely you
know went a little Stone Fox Media oh my
God I remember that dude Chris from
Stone Fox Media I like this video it's
like gonna lie to you man I like this
video even though he was uh Xbox Harry
kind of yeah he was a PlayStation dude
but he was entertaining I actually made
a video
uh
because I was trying his style out but I
I didn't do it more than once I might
have did it twice but yeah I appreciate
it for coming through uh
start working people find you
yeah man check out my channel if you're
an Xbox fan
if you don't mind a little console war
stuff
I'm leaving the link in the description
I mean in the um chat
check out my channel man I got a podcast
on Monday evenings
uh WBZ Xbox podcast got a podcast on
Thursday evening it's called one man
dark man yeah man so um go ahead and um
subscribe if you like it if you're Pro
Xbox you don't mind a little trash talk
a little console or stuff oh I think I
think they they would love that I think
our
audience is definitely Pro console or
see here's the thing
called towards fun
I think people exaggerate too much on
how bad console war stuff is there is
such thing as bad taste and good tasting
Contour Wars and I think a lot of people
just have bad tasting console war stuff
I think you have good tasting Contour
stuff even though you and Alex be you
know I don't know why he went so hard on
on your mic I think he has good taste
and stuff like that but it's just like
some people just they have bad tastes
like they they take the stuff too far
like they take it too far if I listen to
your show and I feel like this consumes
you that's when I know it's gonna go bad
yeah yeah there's a lot of guys that get
really angry about certain points they
really want to fight fight people
because they uh love Xbox and it's crazy
man and there's my channel guys uh Lord
addictile P definitely go over there and
sub to me man if you guys enjoy my
content for I I'm I'm like 70 away from
5 000 Subs on YouTube definitely
appreciate all the support you guys have
been giving I think what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna send you guys to fame you know
you guys know how it is go over there
get famous some love man Fame been
grinding man and you know I always I
always told myself when I get you know
this platform and any platform that I
work on you know get to a certain point
that I'd always try to give back in any
way shape or form that I could and you
know the that's what it comes to this
you know Fame me and him may not have
seen eye to eye about 100 thing but dude
got nothing but passion for uh for
gaming and go over there and show them
some love uh tell them tell them the
attic show sent you man uh
we we are signing out and uh anything
else you want to say before we send
these these folks to over there to fame
nah man peace out y'all all right stay
safe